[suspenseful music]
NARRATOR: In 1859,
biologist Charles Darwin
introduced the
world to the theory
of evolution with his book
on "The Origin of Species."
In it, he proposed that gradual,
multi-generational changes,
occurring due to
natural selection,
had resulted in the modification
of all existing species.
While scientists agree that
this process does, in fact,
take place to some
extent, in recent years,
evidence has been presented
that suggests evolution alone
cannot account for
all the species
present in the animal kingdom.
There is one species of dog.
But look at it, from
chihuahuas to St. Bernards,
to bulldogs,
everything in between.
And all that has happened in
less than a few thousand years.
I mean, this is crazy.
This is like going from this
generalized wolf-like creature
into this huge variety of dogs.
There are fossils of
giraffes with short necks.
And then we have the present.
And there is no
intermediate form.
If you suddenly give
a giraffe a much
longer neck than it had before,
a lot of things have to change.
Its blood pressure
regulation has to change.
It's got to have
a different heart.
It's just going to be
eating different things
with a long neck.
All of that software for the
animal has to be rewritten.
And you're telling me this
all happens overnight?
NARRATOR: Ancient astronaut
theorists propose that if some,
or possibly, all of the
lifeforms on Earth cannot be
explained as the product of
natural selection or evolution,
it may, in fact, offer proof
of not only intelligent design,
but also what they believe to be
extraterrestrial intervention.
And they say the
overwhelming evidence
can be found by examining the
practices of ancient cultures
all over the world.
[suspenseful music]